what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so as a general rule when it comes
to the world of comic books the wild
wonderful joyful world of comic books
there are like four writers that as a
rule if they write something I will read
it and I don't care what it is I will
read anything they write and that's
that's that's just how I work I have
writers and I'm attached to Geoff Johns
Jonathan Hickman Robert Venditti and
then you have Scott Schneider and this
guy I swear to God like it's crazy like
the Batman run he had new 52 is what
really got me in and I was like damn I
mean I know he wrote like black mirror I
think it was but the great thing about
writer is when you're like a really
really good writer is they're not
constrained to like a character or team
or a particular publisher or anything
like that you can feed them anything and
they will turn it into a great story and
that's what this is justice league no
justice is the first part of like a
four-part series that really to me feels
more like a crisis than anything else
but it is pretty solid and it is pretty
amazing now here's the funny thing this
like like a lot of other things like New
Age of Heroes this all comes out of the
events of Dark Knight smell and that's
one of the reasons why I'm gonna throw
this in the Dark Knight's metal playlist
so that people kind of get a full feel
for like the event itself and then like
the aftermath or the significant moments
of aftermath but this kind of picks up
after that whole Dark Knight metal thing
and the idea is that where the Dark
multiverse was basically kept at bay
kind of pushed back and the universe was
saved quote-unquote what's actually
going on here is that the source wall
has been cracked now when it comes to DC
Comics the source is just this thing
that exists out there I do not believe
DC has ever explicitly created like a
one-shot or anything like that that
really explains what the source is it's
just kind of the source of all things
that exist in that's kind of all we get
some argue that it's like God basically
um that it's the the force by which all
life sprang into existence in the DC
Universe but there's the source and the
source wall and I know the source wall
originally debuted in the Chris
Claremont Walt Simonson x-men and
uncanny x-men and teen titans crossover
whenever that was written and then the
source I'm pretty sure the source was
basically stated by Jack Kirby and New
Gods number one in 1971 I'm pretty sure
that's the case but regardless of the
situation the idea is that the source
wall is just kind of what protects
quote-unquote the universe from
whatever's out there
we don't really know definitively what's
on the other side in light of like dark
nights metal like what everything that
happened in the whole dark nights metal
and the dark multiverse all that kind of
stuff there were things like like Yuga
Khan for example the father of Darkseid
who was stuck inside the source wall and
DC was just kind of hinting at the idea
that like he would return but the fact
remains in light of what happened with
Dark Knight's metal the source walls
been cracked and so what does what does
kapenta
potentially mean is that whatever is on
the other side of that source wall could
come through so for those of you guys
who are coming from Marvel Comics think
of this crack in a source wall like the
crack in the universe from Thanos
Imperator really the war of kings going
into Thanos imperative where the other
side of that crack was like the cancer
versus where you had a universe where no
superhero could die and basically
everybody lived and then eventually all
became villains and the universe was
overcrowded with life and so on and so
forth we don't know what's on the other
side of the source wall but it really
seems to be DC's way of kind of saying
like all the things you really miss
they're all coming back and it's all
because of the source wall being cracked
and it's kind of cool because this sets
people in panic mode at the same time
what you end up having is you end up
having like the Suicide Squad that
Titans the Teen Titans the Justice
League all kind of facing off against
this singular threat and we don't really
know what this threat is initially until
we basically pick up with the idea that
it's Brainiac now when it comes to DC
Comics Brainiac is not really a singular
villain I mean the way you see him is
usually depicted as a villain but
Brainiac has a lot of different versions
that appear in the future that have
appeared in the past that was the whole
idea of convergence that story we do not
speak of but you had like all these
different things going on this version
of Brainiac initially seems to be one
that's just looking to conquer earth
so when Superman and the Justice League
initially faced off the idea is that
brainy I just kind of seize him and then
basically says I am NOT coming here as a
conqueror I'm not coming here to capture
your world I'm not coming here to
destroy you and even if even if that was
my goal what chance would you have
because I've defeated every single
superhero team you have and I'm just one
man and so that's that's the whole point
the whole motive of Brainiac being here
is I want to show you how weak you guys
are like that's the whole point here now
it doesn't initially say that instead
what we end up doing here is we
basically pick up with various
individuals who have been captured now
the idea at least the implication seems
to be there they're all being captured
with for particular reasons but this is
something to notice here this is
something that I didn't initially pick
up when I read through this you have the
team Titans fighting together you have
the Titans fighting together you had the
Justice League in the Suicide Squad
fighting together but when they all
start waking
in different rooms they're not with the
teams that they were with the teams are
not the same and so the idea is that
they've basically been captured by
Brainiac and then switched around and we
don't exactly know the motivation for it
but it is cool because this is what
begins you know this is what gives us
the early formations of the Justice loss
teams and so of course what you end up
having is you know Harley Quinn her
ingenuity you know kind of breaking the
wall really is its Hana and Starfire and
Beast Boy out of the room that they're
in and then from there they like we
switch over to Martian Manhunter this is
an important thing to bear in mind -
this is really Martian Manhunter z--
return such as it is to the Justice
League roster because remember you had
the events of like the new 52 and DC's
reboot and you had like the Justice
League team that Martian Manhunter was
on and then like he was gone when DC
rebirth kicked off and we had no idea
what he was doing and we still don't
really know what he was doing and the
result is that with him being back here
now it seems like he's full on part of
the Justice League so in truth it's only
really a matter of time before we
probably get like a one-shot or full-on
expose of everything he's been doing in
the time that he's been gone he's been
soul-searching binge watching Sherlock
Holmes I know I have but the funny thing
about this is that even with this team
things are a little bit different than
we would expect you've got Martian
Manhunter you've got the atom you've got
doctor fate you've got Damian Wayne and
you've got Raven these are not teams
that we normally see together and so
where the question begins to be asked
well why are we here what in the world
is going on then you have the Justice
League who basically shows up with
Brainiac and that's where things begin
to go awry because game Ian's initial
responses well this is ludicrous you
guys are a lying yourselves with what is
potentially like one of the top three
most dangerous beings in the universe
and we're just supposed to roll with it
and that's where things get kind of
crazy is because what I love about this
what sky what what really what Snyder
does is he kind of takes the themes of
like Teen Titans in the in Damian Wayne
and he just kind of rolls them over into
like what we would expect with regards
to this story
so what Brainiac does here is he
basically gives us the explanation and
this is what's awesome about this if you
guys have been reading New Age of Heroes
and if you've been reading like the
aftermath of the stories that come with
Dark Knight's metal DC really seems to
be like encroaching on Marvel territory
pretty hardcore like they're not very
shy about it they're like okay so here
are the things that Marvel is doing in
the MCU and these are here the things
that like fans like in the comics so
like we're just gonna take them and then
we're just gonna make em our own what's
more we're gonna do about it man their
houses in disarray they have no idea
what's going on they can barely get
their house together let alone
like stop us from doing what we're doing
and it kind of makes sense but these
guys these Omega Titans really remind me
more of like a kind of reworked version
of the Celestials than anything else and
here's a reason why so what Brainiac
does is basically say that like there
are these beings called the Omega Titans
and they really kind of predate all
civilization and the implication here is
that they're the oldest things to exist
so really it's said that the oldest
things to exist but the idea is that
like the universe came into existence
and they were the first things to exist
as an aside this is one of the reasons
why I haven't finished a history of the
DC universe yet or while I'll probably
go back and rework it because DC rebirth
is introducing all new things and
changing things up and it wouldn't make
any sense to complete that series and
then have to go back and redo it because
DC changed everything with rebirth and
so the idea is that these are mega
titans basically Webber is an entropy
wisdom Wonder and mystery and so they're
kind of like celestial versions of like
the endless I guess would kind of be a
way to do it but the idea was that these
of these beings these Omega Titans were
essentially like the progenitors of all
life they were kind of like the creators
of all things in existence and so
because of the fact that they kind of
left planets to their own devices what
would happen is they would come together
and they would basically seek through
the entirety of the universe and a
planet that was extremely high in like
wisdom for example would be consumed by
like the brother of wisdom so like the
smartest beings in the universe he would
consume their worlds so it's kind of
like Galactus and the Celestials being
merged together just because of the fact
that I say that in Marvel Comics you
have like arashan the judge right like
you know the Celestials create life on
planets and then they go back every few
thousand years to check on their project
and if they don't like the direction
that it's going in then air should the
judge will judge against the planet and
then exit are well basically like wipe
out all life on that planet and start
all over again and so that's how like
the Celestials always function so the
saloon are the similarities are pretty
strong here but that's the other thing
that Brainiac says is like these beings
can be defeated the problem that you
guys have is the entire structure of
your superhero teams as they've always
existed have never changed the Teen
Titans are always teenagers the Justice
League is always two grown members of
the superhero team usually the first
superheroes in like earthscan in history
in DC Comics and then you have the
Titans who are the new generation of a
team or who were there you know where
the Teen Titans eventually go on to
become its copypasta your teams are
always the same and they never change
and that makes you predictable the whole
idea of this was to basically say I've
split you guys into separate teams
that's why you are where you are because
it makes you unpredictable not only that
he also brought villains into the mix
Starro at your game
Sinestro Lex Luthor Lobo I mean you've
got let you know Deathstroke you've got
some some pretty hardcore villains here
and so it was just kind of like like man
like things are kind of running awry but
of course while all this is going on
you've got Amanda Waller being Amanda
Waller of course the person who's
currently leading the Suicide Squad
basically but what she's done here this
is kind of a cool callback because
you've got like only let's say you've
got like like Maxwell Lord you have well
you got like Hector Hammond and you got
like pretty much the world's most
powerful psychics who have all been
kidnapped by Amanda Waller hooked up to
a singular machine and literally using
the combined efforts of all their brain
power to figure out everything that's
going on or at least to push into the
brain of a brainiac and extract as much
information as humanly possible and so
what ends up happening is you basically
have Brainiac who leads or superheroes
to pollute and what's happened as
Brainiac has basically said I put you in
these teams do not deviate from these
teams you being in these teams are done
for a particular purpose you know and so
if you break away you're all going to
die the problem with this is that when
they arrive to Colo and it's basically
being torn apart by the wisdom Omega
Titan suddenly Amanda Waller initiates
her plan it starts drawing on all the
psychic energy to basically start
jumping into the mind of Brainiac as
fast as she can the problem is that it
is literally a mental overload for
Brainiac which ultimately destroys his
brain and so the problem with this is
that the Justice League is just kind of
out there like the superhero teams are
out there they have no more leadership
of Brainiac all they have to go on is
the teams he put them in and that's it
there's nothing else for them to operate
with so at this point they're on their
own
they gotta figure it out good luck guys
without being said we're gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]